it's almost Halloween and what better
way to celebrate than scaring yourself
silly by playing some of the best and
the most horrifying games on offer yeah
I know Red Dead Redemption is out really
soon too but just stick with me all
right I've got some really good games
here one of them even has sweet gameplay
kickbacks for treating animals nicely so
it's just like Red Dead sort of not
really in any case it's still one of my
favorites from the last handful of years
so let's talk until dawn until dawn is a
fantastic example of classic horror
films colliding with games featuring
some great performances by big-name
actors like rami malek and hayden
Panettiere
this one turned out to be an absolute
gem it began with a bucket of cabin in
the woods cliches and a handful of cheap
jump scares that quickly give way to a
genuinely fascinating story with plenty
of twists character development and that
all-important butterfly effect that
makes until dawn wildly replayable the
relationships between characters change
based on how you treat others while
playing as each of the characters and
these sometimes have dire consequences
if somebody doesn't like you enough to
help you escape a fog until dawn managed
to take celebrity performances QuickTime
events and a bowl of cliches and make
them all work together beautifully
whether you're playing or laughing along
watching somebody who is don't miss out
on this one
put your up in the door it's a separate
reality seeing as I don't want you to
spend a grand on a ps4 on eBay that
still has Petey installed I'll take this
moment to say that of course Petey is a
fantastic horror game but you know what
else is great won't break the bank and
can actually be installed on your
current gen platform of choice Resident
Evil 7 Resident Evil 7 is truly the
product of everything fantastic from the
series so far and the best horror
influences from Pete a losing silent
hill's was a massive blow for horror
fans but Resident Evil 7 knocked it out
of the park
after so many stumbles away from its
horror roots over the last few
installments the terrifying undercurrent
of this game never lets up and there's a
great balance between resource
management and old-school survival
mechanics coupled with newer
action-oriented ones
razzi 7 has an engaging narrative strung
through the center gorgeous visuals to
lock you into the horror of it all and
the ability to arm yourself and blast
the ever
living crap out of all that goes bump in
the night which you'll be thankful for
if you play any of the other games on
this list it's also well worth booting
this one in VR should you have the
necessary hardware for a great scare or
a great laughs depending on which side
of the headset you find yourself you'd
be hard-pressed to find a horror game
from recent years that tops amnesia the
Dark Descent it offers up a spectacular
survival horror undercurrent a sanity
meter that obscures your vision when the
game's frightening foes are in your line
of sight and a gorgeously detailed game
world and if you're a horror fan I'm
guessing you know that though what you
might not know is frictional games as
most recent games soma is a whole other
kind of brilliant
they're still beasties lurking in the
dark and you're as helpless as you were
in the amnesia and penumbra games but
the story is far stronger the game takes
place on an underwater remote research
facility and deals with themes like
philosophy the human condition and AI
soma trades in the massive run and hide
sections from its spiritual predecessor
in favor of elevating the
thought-provoking unsettling sci-fi
narrative the story is complex and
mysterious enough to contribute to the
horror of its own right but there's
still plenty of unearthly creatures
happy to rip out your innards if that's
what you're after if you want something
a little more left-of-center look no
further than little nightmares at its
core it's a 3d side scroller a la inside
but with grotesque and unsettling
visuals that complement what amounts to
a giant game of hide-and-seek you step
into the tiny shoes of six a little kid
in a yellow raincoat trying to escape
all manner of beasties set to spot or
sniff you out chilling sound effects a
massive size differential and horrific
ly realistic disgustingly proportioned
creatures out for blood
make journeying through this one
extremely creepy especially given that
this is one of the rare cases where
seeing your enemy is actually more
frightening than imagining them thanks
to the twisted art style and repulsive
character design the game is as detailed
and beautiful as it is stress inducing
if you're a puzzle platformer fan who
loves a touch of horror you really can't
go wrong with this adventure of hiding
under beds and rekindling childhood
whimsy so long as you're a write with
the occasional mangled foe biting at
your heels
if you'd rather escape threatening
enemies at a full sprint which to be
honest was my favorite way of playing
this game
I'd recommend outlast you spent a
hideous amount of time speeding away
from naked insane asylum inmates and
murder surgeons all of whom you'll have
to light up with your night-vision
camera that gradually runs out of
battery much like amnesia outlast
requires you to solve environmental
puzzles and make your way through areas
quickly and quietly while ensuring you
aren't sane right up until you are and
then you run like hell
the enemies are terrifying the jump
scares are rife and the gore has been
turned up to eleven the eternal chase
through the dark and threatening
Mountain massive asylum never lets up
making it a great game to drop into for
a fright outlast is a fun horror rump
but man there's a lot of people around
like all the time if you're looking for
a more isolating experience why not
check out alien isolation yep that's the
best segue I could come up with doing
much of the heavy lifting and reminding
you aliens are cool after the
significantly less cool aliens colonial
Marines alien isolation will almost
definitely serve up a shriek fest never
knowing quite how much danger you're in
which is emphasized by the aliens
dynamic AI elevates the tension that
underpins the door-opening terminal
accessing and Space Station exploring
that dominates the rest of the game
alien isolation offers a constant
feeling of dread as you use your motion
tracker to get a general idea of where
the alien may be around you running is
rarely a good option since that makes
you noisy and the critter is much faster
than you are forcing you to slow down
hide and endure the fear of being hunted
while continually moving forward is what
makes this one really great
[Music]
all right so maybe you've heard of alien
isolation and outlast let's round this
up with a great game that you may not
have heard of layers of fear layers of
fear is a psychological horror game
where the biggest frets come from your
protagonists mind overshadowing the
jump-scares of which there are plenty is
the destruction of reality and your
trust in the game worlds you play an
artist attempting to complete his life's
work and revealing what has happened to
him and his role in the psychological
nightmare he's found himself in is
really fascinating losing the comfort in
a knowledge of your environment and
learning that you can't trust your
perception is a panic inducing
experience as items and rooms in the
game world constantly warp and change
there are no moments of security you
won't be hunted or pursued in this
four-hour nightmare but the horrors of a
broken reality unsettling audio and
visual design and psychological scares
make layers of fear into a twisted gone
home type experience and in my mind one
of the most frightening on this list let
me know down in that comment box which
horror game you think is the best
what is your scariest moment in gaming
and which of these games you're most
came to try out